HAVE OUR AUTHOR HERE AND WILL
CONVENE IN SECONDS. HI 87654321.
THREE. 42311. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR MEETING IN THE OAK
STREET BUILDING IN ROOM 1200. WE
WOULD ASK ALL MEMBERS CAN COME
TO THE COMMITTEE SO WE CAN
QUICKLY ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TO TODAY'S HEARING. WE HAVE ONE
BILL. ONE BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
AB 3121 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. PUBLIC UTILITIES
INCENTIVES PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. SO I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT OUR AUTHOR COME FORWARD
AND FORWARD AND PRESENT HER ONE
ITEM VÀ AB 3264. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS.
BEFORE I BEGIN, JUST FOR THE
AVOIDANCE OF DOUBT, THIS ITEM IS
NOT THE BILL WITH THE 10:06 P.M.
TIME STAMP. SO LET ME JUST START
WITH THE GOOD NEWS UP FRONT. I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 3264, A BILL TO ADDRESS
ENERGY AFFORDABILITY. AS WE ALL
KNOW, CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY
BILLS ARE SKYROCKETING. MOST
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS HAVE SEEN A
50% INCREASE IN THEIR BILLS IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS ALONE. AS
WE ALL KNOW, TOO MANY CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. AB 3264 WILL START TO
BEND THE COST CURVE AND BRING
DOWN BILLS FOR HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. THIS PROPOSAL ACTS
ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE
EMERGED FROM HEARINGS ON
AFFORDABILITY THAT HAVE BEEN
HELD THIS YEAR BY BOTH YOUR
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS BY THE
ASSEMBLY'S UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE. THE BILL DOES THREE
CRITICAL THINGS. IT STARTS BY
MAKING AFFORDABILITY A PRIORITY.
AB 3264 ESTABLISHES AN
AFFORDABILITY TARGET THAT WILL
SHAPE DECISION MAKING MOVING
FORWARD. THE BILL DIRECTS THE
CPUC TO EVALUATE HOUSEHOLD'S
OVERALL ENERGY BURDEN AND
DEVELOP STRATEGIES, AND A
FRAMEWORK TO REDUCE TOTAL ENERGY
COSTS BY 2035. LOOKING AT A 5%,
10%, AND 15% SCENARIO, THIS
FRAMEWORK WILL THEN BE USED TO
EVALUATE IOU REVENUE REQUESTS.
NUMBER TWO, THE BILL INITIATES A
VALUE FOR MONEY REVIEW OF THE
HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC PURPOSE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDED BY RATEPAYERS. AND NUMBER
THREE, THE BILL COMMISSIONS A
STUDY ON PUBLIC FINANCING FOR
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE. AS
I KNOW, WE ALL KNOW, IN ORDER TO
DELIVER ON OUR CLEAN ENERGY
GOALS, WE NEED TO INCREASE
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY BY 350%.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE DO SO
MOST COST EFFECTIVELY, AND SO
THAT PROVISION WILL ADDRESS THAT
REALLY URGENT NEED. LASTLY, I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
BILL, IT'S NOT THE INTENT OF OUR
BILL TO ADD BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS ON DEMAND SIDE
REPORTING. I AIM TO WORK WITH
THE ENERGY ENTITIES AND THE CPUC
ON ENSURING THAT WE IMPLEMENT
THAT SECTION MOST EFFECTIVELY
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
TODAY. TAKEN TOGETHER, THIS
SUITE OF SOLUTIONS WILL SET THE
STAGE FOR US TO LOWER BILLS FOR
EVERYONE AND TO PUT MORE MONEY
BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. WITH THAT,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND LOOK
FORWARD TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. BEFORE WE GET INTO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION, LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SECRETARY, WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE. DELHI. HERE.
DELHI. HERE. ASHBY ASHBY. HERE.
BECKER. BECKER. HERE. CABALLERO.
DODD. DODD. HERE. DURAZO. HERE.
RAZO. HERE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. HERE.
GONZALEZ. HERE. GONZALEZ. HERE.
GROVE. LIMÓN Ã. LIMON. HERE.
MIN. MIN. HERE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN.
HERE. RUBIO PRESENT AS WELL.
RUBIO. PRESENT. CIERTO. I AM
HERE. CIERTO. HERE. SKINNER.
STERN. STERN. HERE. WILK MEMBERS
OF QUORUM IS PRESENT NOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. DO YOU HAVE ANY
PRINCIPLE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
YOU HAVE TWO WILL SUPPORT THEM.
TWO MINUTES. MY WITNESSES. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
KATIE MARCONI. I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
A LONG TERM ADVOCATE FOR
RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYERS AT THE
CPUC. TURN IS HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB 3264. AB 3264 WILL PROVIDE
THE COMMISSION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IMPORTANT TOOLS FOR
IMPLEMENTING LONG TERM RATEPAYER
SAVINGS TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. WE NEED
MORE INFORMATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS. DRIVERS. AB 3264
DIRECTS THE CPUC TO DEVELOP A
TOOL TO TRACK THE OVERALL ENERGY
COSTS THAT EACH HOUSEHOLD FACES.
THESE TOOLS WILL PROVIDE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ON THE
DEPTH OF THE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS BY INCLUDING ALL ENERGY
COSTS FROM UTILITY BILLS TO
TRANSPORTATION FUEL COSTS. THESE
METRICS CAN BE USED TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND NEW UTILITY SPENDING
REQUESTS AND EVALUATE THEM. THE
THE BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
UTILITIES TO VISUALIZE WHERE
THEY ARE SPENDING THEIR MONEY,
AND THE COSTS THAT ARE IN
RESIDENTIAL RATEPAYERS RATES,
AND ADDRESSING THE CRISIS WILL
ALSO NEED THAT. WE MEAN THAT WE
NEED TO CONSIDER SOME CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS. OUR ELECTRICAL GRID
WILL NEED SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN THE FUTURE, SPECIFICALLY
TRANSMISSION UPGRADES. THESE
UPGRADE COSTS WILL HAVE TO
COMPETE WITH OTHER SPENDING
PRIORITIES AND WITHOUT ANOTHER
SOLUTION TO FUND THESE UPGRADES,
IT WILL EXACERBATE OUR HIGH
RATES. AB 3264 PREPARES US TO
FACE THIS PROBLEM AND DIRECTS
THE STUDY OF ALTERNATIVE
FINANCING. THIS STUDY WILL
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPARE AND CONTRAST DIFFERENT
METHODS OF PAYING FOR THESE
INVESTMENTS, AND WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO PLAN AHEAD TO MANAGE
THE RATE INCREASES. ADDRESSING
AFFORDABILITY MEANS ACTING NOW
AND LOOKING AHEAD INTO THE
FUTURE, SO THESE PROBLEMS DO NOT
WORSEN. THESE AND OTHER
PROVISIONS OF AB 3264 PROVIDE
KEY DATA POINTS TO INFORM FUTURE
POLICY. TURN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS,
TARA ANDREWS. I'M REPRESENTING
THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 3264. THE PACE AND
SCALE OF ELECTRICITY RATES
INCREASES WILL NOT STOP WITHOUT
INTERVENTION. WE ESTIMATE THAT
ELECTRICITY RATE CRISIS FACED BY
CUSTOMERS WILL CONTINUE UNLESS
SWIFT ACTION IS TAKEN. AB 3264
PROMOTES CRITICAL ACTIVITIES
THAT PROVIDE A SOLID PATH
FORWARD FOR PUTTING DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON RISING ELECTRICITY
RATES AND BILLS. SPECIFICALLY,
THE BILL REQUIRES THE PUC TO
ESTABLISH AN ENERGY COST
FRAMEWORK TO IDENTIFY AND TRACK
MAJOR COST DRIVERS AND ASSESS
THE IMPACT OF THE ENERGY COSTS
ON HOUSEHOLDS. THIS FRAMEWORK
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
PRIORITIZE HOW RATEPAYER FUNDING
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE USED. IN
ADDITION, THIS BILL INCREASES
THE VISIBILITY ON DEMAND SIDE
PROGRAMS SO THAT DECISION MAKERS
CAN MAKE DETERMINE THE BENEFITS
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND ENSURE
THAT RATEPAYERS ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO THE STATE'S ENERGY POLICY
GOALS. LASTLY, THE BILL TAKES
THE IMPORTANT STEP OF INITIATING
A STUDY TO IDENTIFY OPTIONS FOR
REDUCING THE COST OF
TRANSMISSION EXPANSION. THIS IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE WHILE UPGRADING
AND EXPANDING CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM IS NECESSARY
TO ACHIEVE THE STATE'S ENERGY
POLICY GOALS, IT IS ALSO ONE OF
THE PRIMARY COST DRIVERS FOR
RATEPAYERS. IN SUMMARY, OUR
OFFICE SUPPORTS AB 3264 BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
FOUNDATION TO REDUCE AND CONTROL
COSTS AND WHICH WILL PROVIDE
LONG TERM RELIEF TO ELECTRIC
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
BEING REALLY BURDENED BY HIGH
UTILITY RATE BILLS. SO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW, OUR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
STATE YOUR ORGANIZATION. PLEASE
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, VICTORIA
ROEHM WITH NRDC IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS,
EDSON PEREZ, ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED.
EARTHJUSTICE. THE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION COALITION, AND
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP IN SUPPORT. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AARON NIEMELA,
REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL. WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SOME SPECIFICS GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DANIEL BROWN, ON BEHALF OF UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT. CAITLIN SUTTER, ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARCUS, REPRESENTING
CALPIRG IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALEX JACKSON WITH THE AMERICAN
CLEAN POWER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHRIS ROSA,
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, ARE THERE ANY
TWEENERS ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE?
SEEING NONE. GREAT JOB. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. IT'S WE HAVE A
QUESTION BY SENATOR BECKER. GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU. FIRST OF
ALL, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I KNOW
THIS YEAR WE'VE ALL BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT, ABOUT RATES AND
THE COST OF RATES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WHAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE HERE IS YOU'RE
LOOKING BIG PICTURE AT WHAT ARE
THE REALLY SIGNIFICANT THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO OVER TIME TO
REALLY TAKE A CUT INTO RATES IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY. AND I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE WILL
SET US UP TO DO THAT, YOU KNOW,
A COUPLE OF THINGS I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT SPECIFICALLY,
ADJUSTING THE FIRST OF THE
FRAMEWORK FOR UNDERSTANDING
RATEPAYER TOTAL ENERGY COSTS. I
THINK IS FANTASTIC AND REALLY
IMPORTANT, IT SEEMS LIKE A GREAT
IDEA ADJUSTING THE PUC REPORT ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS. LOOK
AT WHICH ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING. AGAIN,
THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF WE
SHOULD BE DOING HERE. STUDYING
WAYS TO SAVE MONEY ON
TRANSMISSION, BUILD OUT
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT JUST A LITTLE
CONCERN. YOU KNOW, JUST MAKE
SURE WE CAN. SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
TO WAIT FOR REPORTS. SO WE CAN
DO LEGISLATION. SO WE JUST GOT
TO FIGURE THAT OUT NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE I THINK WE PROBABLY WANT
TO TAKE SOME ACTION. BUT I'M
EXCITED TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT. AND THEN I THINK THE
TRANSPARENCY ON COSTS ARE
POSITIVE. JUST TO FLAG A COUPLE
OF THINGS TO WORK ON OVER TIME
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT, COST RELATED
TO NEM AND BT, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
KNOW, JUST HOW COST IS DEFINED,
IN THIS AS WE'VE SORT OF SEEN
THAT THROWN AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK IS JUST IMPORTANT. AND
THEN I NOTED THAT IT COST CALLS
OUT COSTS RELATED TO ENERGY
ENERGIZATION AS A SEPARATE
CATEGORY, AND FEELS LIKE THAT
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE SEPARATE
FROM REGULAR, YOU KNOW,
DISTRIBUTION GRID COSTS, BECAUSE
WE CERTAINLY EXPECT UTILITIES TO
PROVIDE TIMELY SERVICE, WHICH
WAS THE WHOLE GOAL OF THAT
EFFORT, SO I JUST, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF FLAG THOSE TWO THINGS
MAYBE TO DISCUSS IN THE FUTURE,
BUT JUST REALLY HAPPY. I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO GO A LONG WAY
TO LETTING US TAKE THAT, THAT
BIG PICTURE AND REALLY MAKE A
DENT THAT WE ALL WANT, A
MEANINGFUL DENT THAT WE ALL WANT
TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS,
SENATOR. AND I THINK TO THE
POINT YOU MADE ABOUT THE REPORT
ON ALTERNATIVE FINANCING FOR
TRANSMISSION. CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW, FOR ME, FOR YOU, I THINK
FOR EVERYBODY HERE, WE DON'T
JUST WANT TO HAVE A REPORT THAT
THEN GOES AND SITS ON A SHELF.
SO THE TURNAROUND DATE FOR THAT
IS JULY OF NEXT YEAR WITH THE
ANTICIPATION THEN THAT IT'S
GOING TO GIVE US SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT INSIGHTS SO WE CAN
TAKE THAT NEXT STEP TO DIG IN
AND MAKE THAT POLICY AND START
SAVING SUBSTANTIAL MONEY ON
TRANSMISSION BUILD OUT. GREAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZZO, AND
THANK YOU FOR WITHDRAWING THE
OTHER BILL. YOU'RE WELCOME. IT
WAS IMPORTANT. AND I'M. IT GOES
TO SHOW THAT YOU WERE LISTENING,
AND OTHERS, YOU KNOW, OTHERS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL ARE
LISTENING. BUT I WANT TO. I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU OUTLINED AS
ONE OF THE PRINCIPLES OF THIS
REPORT OR STUDY AFFORDABILITY. I
INTRODUCED, LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR ON THE AFFORDABILITY OF
WATER BECAUSE WE HAVE MILLIONS
OF FAMILIES THAT ARE IN DEBT
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT FINISH
PAYING THEIR, THEIR WATER BILLS.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO I DON'T
MEAN YOU PERSONALLY, BUT IF
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
AFFORDABILITY A PRIORITY, WHAT
HAS BEEN THE PRIORITY? I MEAN,
HAS IT NOT BEEN I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WILL CHANGE IF
WE'VE TALKED, WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT AFFORDABILITY, BUT WHAT
HAVE WE DONE AND WHAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE NOW? WHAT'S GOING TO
BRING THE KIND OF RELIEF THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND THAT
PEOPLE ARE DEMANDING BECAUSE
THEY JUST CANNOT MAKE IT, WHAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE AND HASN'T
AFFORDABILITY BEEN A PRIORITY UP
UNTIL NOW? SO WHAT'S GOING TO
HOW IS THIS GOING TO CHANGE
THINGS? SO I THINK THAT WE ALL
KNOW THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A REALLY PROFOUND TRANSITION.
SO THIS IS A PIVOTAL MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA AS WE WORK TO BUILD
OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE AND
ACHIEVE OUR CLEAN ENERGY
OBJECTIVES, I'M A BIG BELIEVER
THAT THOSE ARE, YOU KNOW, OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR OUR STATE
AND THAT AS WE BUILD THAT
FUTURE, WE'VE GOT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR ENERGY POLICY BALANCES WHAT
I KIND OF CALL THE THREE LEGS,
YOU KNOW, THREE LEGS OF A STOOL.
SO WE NEED A POLICY THAT'S
SUSTAINABLE, WE'VE ALSO GOT TO
FOCUS ON RELIABILITY, AND WE'VE
GOT TO FOCUS ON AFFORDABILITY.
AND RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC GOALS
AROUND AFFORDABILITY THAT WE
THEN UTILIZE TO BALANCE
DECISIONS AND WEIGH TRADEOFFS.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANTLY
MISSING. AND I THINK
PARTICULARLY AS WE ENTER INTO
THIS PERIOD OF HUGE
TRANSFORMATION AND HUGE BUILD
OUT AND HUGE INVESTMENT, WE NEED
TO HAVE THAT FRONT AND CENTER TO
HELP INFORM OUR POLICYMAKING AND
TO HELP SHAPE AGENCIES ACTIONS,
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND I DO
THINK THAT THERE'S THERE ARE SO
MANY AREAS OF OPPORTUNITY JUST,
YOU KNOW, ONE KIND OF NUGGET
THAT THAT CAME OUT, I THINK, IN,
THE HEARING THAT YOU HAD ON
AFFORDABILITY AS WELL AS THE
HEARING THAT THE ASSEMBLY HAD ON
AFFORDABILITY WHEN WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE COST OF
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE. SO
RIGHT NOW, THAT IS BEING
FINANCED IN PERHAPS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE POSSIBLE WAY. SO IT'S
FINANCED OFF OF IOUS, BALANCE
SHEETS AND CREDIT RATINGS, THEY
HAVE VERY, VERY HIGH RATES OF
BORROWING. ALL OF THOSE COSTS
ARE THEN PASSED ON TO RATEPAYERS
WITH AN ADDITIONAL RATE OF
RETURN. THE KIND OF STAT ONE OF
THE ECONOMIC ECONOMISTS SHARED
WITH US, IF WE JUST SUBSTITUTED
THE BORROWING COSTS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, IF WE DID NOTHING
ELSE BUT SUBSTITUTE THE
BORROWING COSTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE BORROWING
COSTS OF ONE OF OUR IOUS, WE
WOULD BE SAVING 33% OF PROJECT
COSTS. SO THAT'S WHY THAT'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY. AND I
THINK SUCH A CLEAR OPPORTUNITY
FOR SAVINGS. AND SO I'M EXCITED
FOR US TO REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE FOR US TO TRULY
IMPLEMENT A PUBLIC FINANCING
OPTION IN A WAY THAT SAVES
TAXPAYERS AND RATEPAYERS MONEY.
IF I COULD JUST FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS, I CARE ABOUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. HOWEVER, THERE ARE
CALIFORNIANS A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER WHO ARE UNABLE TO PAY
EVEN THE MOST MINIMAL, BILLS FOR
ELECTRICITY AND OTHER UTILITIES.
SO I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE A
VERY SPECIFIC ANALYSIS OF THE
IMPACT THAT IT'S HAVING ON THE
VARIOUS LEVELS OF INCOME THAT
PEOPLE RECEIVE THROUGH THROUGH
THE STATE. WE CAN'T WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LET PEOPLE THE WORKING
POOR. I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK. WHAT IS THE
IMPACT ON THEM? IT COULD BE 50%
HIGHER OF THEIR INCOME THAN
SOMEBODY ELSE. SO I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO SEE THAT BECAUSE THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION, WITHOUT IT,
WE'RE GOING TO BE MAKING POLICY
THAT WILL HURT THEM EVEN MORE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING A
BIG PICTURE. LOOK HERE. AND, FOR
BEING MAGNANIMOUS IN HOW YOU'VE
APPROACHED NOT JUST THIS BILL,
BUT, THE OTHER LEGISLATION THAT
WAS GOING TO BE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE GENERAL SPIRIT
THAT YOU BRING TO THIS, WHICH IS
JUST TRY TO KEEP THINGS MOVING
FORWARD HERE. I HONESTLY THINK
THIS COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
THINGS, WHICH DOESN'T OBVIATE
THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT WHAT'S IN
31, 21, I'M SURE THOSE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE
ABOUT ALL THOSE PROGRAMS. BUT TO
DO SOMETHING HOLISTIC HERE, TO
ME, FEELS LIKE THE RIGHT
APPROACH, AND HOLISTIC, NOT JUST
IN THE SENSE OF ELECTRIC SECTOR
OR THE GAS SECTOR, BUT ALL
ENERGY SECTORS. I AM CONCERNED
THAT, WHEREAS WE HAVE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND ALL
THESE RATEPAYER ADVOCATES ON THE
ELECTRIC AND GAS SIDE, THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO OIL, DIESEL,
PROPANE, THOSE SORT OF
UNREGULATED MARKETS THAT PEOPLE
ARE DEPENDENT ON FOR THEIR
ENERGY, THAT WE STILL DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TOOLS, ENOUGH DATA. I'M
REALLY HOPING THAT THAT SORT OF
FULL BILL ANALYSIS, I THINK IT'S
DUE BY THE END OF 26. I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
TIMELINE, BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE IF
WE DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
IN OUR HANDS COMING IN, YOU
KNOW, SOONER THAN THAT, SAY,
EVEN NEXT YEAR, AS WE GET INTO
BIGGER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT, SAY,
CAP AND TRADE, WHERE BOTH OIL
AND GAS ARE IN THE SAME PROGRAM
AS ELECTRIC SECTOR, THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MISS THOSE SORT OF
COMPREHENSIVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
CUT PEOPLE'S BILLS, I'M TRYING
TO THINK OF WHAT THOSE INTERIM
OPPORTUNITIES ARE TO GET THAT
DATA AND SORT OF FEED THAT INTO
OUR PROCESS. SO I'M HOPING THAT
WE SORT OF DON'T HANG ALL OUR
HOPES JUST ON THIS ONE REPORT.
IN HOW MANY YEARS IS THAT
WHATEVER AFTER NEXT SESSION,
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING
SOME BIG THINGS NEXT SESSION. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON THAT, BUT, BUT I AM, YOU KNOW,
FOR, FOR EXAMPLE, IF, THE
DEPARTMENT OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT IS NOT GIVEN ADEQUATE
AUTHORITY TO KEEP LOOKING AT
BOTH REFINING, AS WELL AS THE
WHOLESALE MARKET AND HOW IT
RELATES TO THE RETAIL MARKET.
THIS SESSION, WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAMSTRUNG GOING INTO NEXT YEAR.
SO DO YOU HAVE A ANYTHING TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THAT CONCERN
THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU WAIT, WE'LL
BE WAITING TWO YEARS BASICALLY
FOR THAT KIND OF DATA TO COME
BACK. AND WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
GET IN THE MEANTIME TO HELP GIVE
US TOOLS? WELL THANKS FOR THAT
QUESTION. BECAUSE AS I SAID, YOU
KNOW, EARLIER, NONE OF US WANT
TO CREATE SOME REPORT THAT WE
FORGET WE EVEN ASKED FOR. AND
THEN NOBODY READS, RIGHT. LIKE,
THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT WHAT WE
WANT TO DO. SO WITH THIS
PROPOSAL, AS I SAID, THE
ANALYSIS ON ALTERNATIVE
FINANCING FOR TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE DONE, IN
JULY OF 2025. THE ADDITIONAL
DATA COLLECTION SO THAT WE CAN
INITIATE A LEGISLATIVE REVIEW
AND, YOU KNOW, A DATA DRIVEN
ASSESSMENT OF THE 300 ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS THAT ARE A
RATEPAYER FUNDED, THAT TOO, WILL
BE DONE BY JULY OF 2025. IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THE, I THINK,
FOUNDATIONAL INFORMATION THAT
WE'LL GET FROM THE ENERGY BURDEN
REPORT AND THE KIND OF SCENARIO
PLANNING AND GOAL SETTING PIECE
THAT COMES IN 2026. THERE'S A
TON OF WORK THAT WE CAN ALL DO
TOGETHER IN THE MEANTIME. AND I
KNOW THIS IS A SHARED PRIORITY
FOR EVERYONE ON THIS DAIS. AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A TON OF
THINGS THAT WE CAN TACKLE. AS WE
SAW THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, THERE WERE QUITE A FEW
PROPOSALS AROUND AFFORDABILITY
THAT CAME, YOU KNOW, BOTH FROM
YOUR SIDE OF THE HOUSE AS WELL
AS FOR OURS. MANY OF THOSE
DIDN'T MAKE IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, I WOULD LOVE TO, TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE COME TOGETHER AND
PULL, PULL TOGETHER, SORT OF A
BICAMERAL GROUP OF FOLKS WHO
REALLY WANT TO DIG IN AND WORK
ON THIS AND COME UP WITH, YOU
KNOW, WHAT I THINK IS GOING TO
BE A MULTIYEAR PLAN TO ACTUALLY
TACKLE THIS ISSUE. THERE'S NOT,
YOU KNOW, A SECRET MAGIC WAND
THAT ANY OF US ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO WAVE. BUT I REALLY,
REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES I WANT US TO WORK
TOGETHER TO TACKLE THOSE. AND
I'LL ALSO NOTE, AND I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THIS, THE STATUS QUO,
STATUS QUO IS WORKING GREAT FOR
SOME STAKEHOLDERS, RIGHT? WHICH
CAN MAKE IT REALLY HARD FOR US
TO PUSH POLICIES THAT CHANGE
THAT, SO LOOK FORWARD TO DIGGING
IN, BUT CERTAINLY MY EXPECTATION
ISN'T, OH, WE'RE GOING TO PASS
THIS AND THEN REGROUP IN TWO
YEARS. OKAY. THAT'S DONE. THAT'S
THAT MEANS A LOT. THAT'S
REASSURING, I THINK THE IDEA OF
A BICAMERAL PROCESS AND DOING
SOME OF THAT WORK, THROUGH THE
OFF SEASON, IS ACTUALLY A WISE
IDEA. SO I'D SIGN UP FOR THAT
EFFORT. I'LL JUST FLAG THE TWO
BIGGIES FOR ME THAT I HOPE
THEY'RE THEY'RE CONTAINED IN THE
BILL. BUT THERE'S PUC WORK.
UNDERWAY THAT I HOPE ALSO
CULMINATES IN TIME, ON THE GAS
SIDE OF THINGS, THE BILL CALLS
OUT, COST DUE TO COMMODITY
PRICES AS WELL AS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH, SEPARATING
TRANSMISSION COSTS IN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COMMISSION
VERSUS THE JURISDICTION OF FERC,
I THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS. AND PUC CURRENTLY HAS
AN INVESTIGATION, ALONGSIDE
FERC, PER OUR DIRECTION, TO LOOK
AT THOSE GAS SPIKES OF A COUPLE
YEARS BACK THAT COST PEOPLE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS THROUGH A VERY COLD
WINTER, AND PEOPLE STILL HAVEN'T
BEEN MADE WHOLE FROM THAT. I
THINK THAT WE'VE GOT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT
INVESTIGATION, AND I HOPE THAT
DATA WILL YIELD SOME LONGER TERM
LOOKS. SO WE DON'T GO THROUGH
THOSE SPIKES AGAIN. AND THEN THE
OTHER PIECE, WHICH IS NOT IN
THIS BILL, BUT IT'S IN ANOTHER
BILL PENDING, FROM SENATOR
SKINNER, IS, IS THE REFINING
COST IMPACTS AND MAKING SURE WE
HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
PETROLEUM SIDE OF THE MARKET
BECAUSE THOSE ARE JUST THE
WHOLESALE MARKET FOR GAS TRADING.
AND THE PETROLEUM SIDE ARE A
WILD WEST AND IN THIS ELECTRIC
SIDE. SO, BUT I'M READY TO HAVE
THOSE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS TO AND
FROM 3121, I THINK WE SHOULD PUT
IT ALL ON THE TABLE. SO I'D MOVE
THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I HAVE A MOTION,
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU. I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT HERE.
EVERYONE'S. THANK YOU FOR THIS.
AND I KNOW ONE OF MY BIGGEST, I
WOULD SAY SADNESS IS THAT I KNOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BRING
RELIEF, IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
RATEPAYERS AND I KNOW THAT WHEN
WE PASS POLICIES LIKE THESE, YOU
KNOW, OUR CONSUMERS HEAR ABOUT
IT AND THEY EXPECT TO SEE IT
THIS YEAR AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SEVERAL YEARS. BUT I WANT TO
PIGGYBACK ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES. THIS IS THE REASON
WE WERE BEING A LITTLE RESISTANT
WITH OTHER IDEAS THAT WE SHARE.
VERY SIMILAR DEMOGRAPHICS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO EXPLORE, THAT THE
DIFFERENCE IN INCOMES, IN TERMS
OF HOW DO WE BRING RELIEF TO
THOSE THAT ARE REALLY IN THE
BRINK OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
SUSTAIN IT? AND AS DATA COMES
FORWARD, WE NEED TO REALLY SEE
WHAT WE CAN HELP IN THAT REGARD.
AND THAT'S ALL I WOULD ASK. BUT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
I KNOW THAT WE WANT RELIEF,
IMMEDIATE RELIEF, AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT WE GET THERE FASTER,
BUT THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU. I KNOW IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ANTICIPATED IN
THIS STUDY. THE STUDY REGARDING
THE, TRANSMISSION IS ABOUT
ALTERNATIVE FINANCING. I JUST
RAISED THAT, GIVEN THAT ALL OF
US ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY, AND THAT IS ONE
OF THE KEY MOTIVATIONS OF THIS
STUDY THAT WE MIGHT ALSO
ENCOURAGE THAT THERE BE A CLEAR
LOOK AT THE NECESSITY FOR THE
LEVEL OF TRANSMISSION THAT'S
BEING PROJECTED. AND I RAISE
THAT, AND PEOPLE MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT ME LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WOOHOO! WE'RE ELECTRIFYING. OF
COURSE WE NEED ALL OF THAT. I
WILL BRING US BACK TO THE 70S
WHEN THE PROJECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE OF OUR
ELECTRICITY USE, WAS THAT WE
WERE GOING TO NEED MAJOR NEW
POWER PLANTS UP AND DOWN THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA, SITED ABOUT
EVERY 100 TO 200 MILES. SO IN
OTHER WORDS, ANOTHER, AT LEAST
20 WERE PROJECTED AT THAT POINT.
THAT IS ALSO THE TIME WHEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STARTED THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION FIRST DID
REFRIGERATOR APPLIANCE STANDARDS
FOR EFFICIENCY, AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY ADDITIONAL. BUT THE
ACTION JUST OF REDUCING THE
ELECTRICITY DRAW OF
REFRIGERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CUT CALIFORNIA'S PER
CAPITA ELECTRICITY USE BY AT
LEAST 20%, JUST REFRIGERATORS.
AND WITH THE ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS IN DEMAND THAT CAME
ABOUT BECAUSE OF SOME CHANGES,
THOSE POWER PLANTS WERE NOT
NEEDED. AND I RAISE IT BECAUSE,
YES, WE ABSOLUTELY ARE COMMITTED
TO ELECTRIFYING. YES WE WANT TO
ELECTRIFY OUR TRANSPORTATION.
THAT LOGICALLY MEANS WE WILL
NEED MORE GENERATION AND
POTENTIALLY MORE TRANSMISSION.
BUT THERE IS STILL A VERY STRONG
ROLE FOR NEGAWATTS. WHAT THAT
BREAKTHROUGH IS TO ACHIEVE THOSE
WE MAY NOT KNOW YET. I DOUBT
THAT PEOPLE IN, SAY, THE 60S
THOUGHT THAT REFRIGERATORS COULD
BE MADE GREATLY MORE EFFICIENT.
RIGHT, JUST AS, ANYWAY, WE WON'T
GIVE MORE ANALOGIES, BUT THE
POINT BEING IS THAT I THINK WE
WOULD BE. IT WOULD BE SILLY TO
MISS THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE OUR
BEST MINDS. ALSO, LOOK AT WHAT
ELSE WE COULD DO AS WE ELECTRIFY
TO BRING DOWN THAT DEMAND,
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S
GOING TO SAVE OUR RATEPAYERS
COSTS. APPRECIATE IT. YES AND I
THINK YEAH, I THINK THERE'S A
TON OF OPPORTUNITY WITH EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES BOTH ON THAT SIDE
AND AS YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW,
WITH GRID ENHANCING
TECHNOLOGIES, SOME OF WHICH
EXIST TODAY, SOME OF WHICH ARE
IN DEVELOPMENT, THERE'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO GET EVEN MORE OUT OF CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN IN
CALIFORNIA TO INCENTIVIZE,
INCENTIVIZE THAT. THANK YOU,
VICE CHAIR. DALEO. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. SO REAL QUICK, I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT
I WANT TO SAY WE HAVE A REPORT,
SB 695 REPORT CAME OUT LAST
MONTH. AND WHAT DID IT TELL US?
IT TOLD US THAT WILDFIRE AND
NIMS ARE THE ONE OF THE BIG
FACTORS OF COST. OBVIOUSLY, THIS
BILL IS GOING TO ADDRESS
FINANCING, WHICH I THINK IS A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY FOR, YOU KNOW,
IF WE CAN GET OUR MONEY CHEAPER,
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S GOING TO DRIVE
DOWN THE RATES. BUT I JUST WANT
TO SAY FOR THE RECORD, WHAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE IN THIS STUDY
IS THE POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS HOUSE
AND THE OTHER HOUSE ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE 100% RENEWABLE
IN THIS TIME. THAT COST IS
DRIVING THAT. THOSE POLICIES ARE
DRIVING THE COST. BUT NOBODY
EVER TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND WE CAN'T REALLY DO GOOD
PLANNING UNTIL WE KNOW WHAT THE
POLICIES THAT WE'RE DRIVING IS,
DRIVING THE COST UP. AND YOU
SAID THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE
HAPPY ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION. I
HAVEN'T FOUND ANYBODY THAT THE
UTILITIES OR CUSTOMERS THAT ARE
HAPPY WITH CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
POLICIES AND THE COST. SO I'LL
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE POLICIES THAT ARE PASSED
BECAUSE THEY'RE DRIVING UP THE
COST OF ELECTRICITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND TRYING TO MEET
THESE TARGETS IN A TIME FRAME IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, THANK YOU. ANY MORE
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I DO WANT
TO THANK, THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THIS MEASURE. AND COMING
FORTH, AS STATED BY ALL MY
COLLEAGUES, COST IS A MAJOR
CONCERN, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
SECTOR WE'RE LOOKING AT WHEN IT
COMES TO ENERGY. AND I DO WANT
TO KIND OF ECHO WHAT MY VICE
CHAIR STATED. I MEAN, WE HAVE TO
KIND OF LOOK AT OURSELVES, TOO
AND TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO DRIVE THOSE
COSTS. IT'S GOOD TO BE
ASPIRATIONAL. IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
GOALS, BUT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THOSE ASPIRATIONAL GOALS HAVE
REAL COST IMPACTS AND RESTRAINTS
ON WHAT WE DO. AS A STATE AS IT
RELATES TO DELIVERING THIS POWER.
SO I HOPE THE STUDY WILL LOOK AT
THAT AS WELL, BECAUSE, AGAIN, WE
HEAR FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS, WE
HEAR FROM BUSINESSES. AND THE
MAJOR REASON WHY BUSINESSES ARE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA IS NOT
BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE OTHER
FACTORS, BUT THEY SAY
UNCERTAINTY ON THEIR ENERGY
COSTS. WE'VE HEARD IT FROM MANY
BUSINESSES. THE UNCERTAINTY AND
BUSINESSES NEED CERTAINTY. AND
WHEN THEIR RATES ARE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING, IT MAKES IT FAR TOO
HARD TO DO BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I APPRECIATE
THIS, AND I HOPE IT, PROVIDES
THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO WORK IN A COLLABORATIVE
MANNER TO GO FORWARD. SO AT THAT
POINT, I MEAN, AT THIS POINT,
I'M GOING TO LET YOU CLOSE. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND JUST PICKING
UP YOUR ON YOUR COMMENTS, WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS HAVING A
TERRIBLE IMPACT ON HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. AS YOU
SAID, IT'S ALSO A TREMENDOUS
RISK TO OUR ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT AND OUR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE GREAT NEW
JOBS AND BE THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY. SO I THINK FOR
ALL OF THOSE REASONS, THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY, INCREDIBLY URGENT
ISSUE, IT'S ONE THAT I KNOW IS A
FRIEND OF MINE FOR YOU, FOR THE
COMMITTEE, AND CERTAINLY FOR ME
AND MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU AS WE BOTH MOVE THIS MEASURE
FORWARD AND IMPLEMENT IT. SHOULD
IT BECOME REALITY, AND TO DO
WORK ON ALL FRONTS SO THAT WE
CAN, AS, AS WE SAID, LOWER BILLS
AND PUT MORE MONEY INTO THE
POCKETS OF HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. SO WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR MEN, AND WE
HAVE A Dð PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I DALLI DALLI
I ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER I
BECKER I CABALLERO I CABALLERO I
DODD I DODD I DURAZZO I DURAZZO
I EGGMAN GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
GROVE LIMÓN LIMÓN I MIN. BLESS
YOU. THANK YOU MEN I MIN I
NEWMAN NEWMAN I RUBIO I RUBIO I
CIERTO CIERTO I SKINNER. SKINNER
I STERN STERN I WILK I WILK I 16
TO 0 SIX. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE HAS 16 VOTES MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WE WANT TO THANK YOU
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED WORK. AND I JUST WANT
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR A
VERY, VERY PRODUCTIVE YEAR.
HOPEFULLY, THIS IS OUR LAST
HEARING. WE MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER
ONE. SO BUT BUT BUT MR. CHAIR,
MR. CHAIR. COME ON BACK. I DODD
YOU MAY NOT BE DONE, BUT I THINK
SINCE YOU ARE RETIRING, I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT JOB,
THE GREAT WORK YOU'VE DONE ALL
YEAR LONG. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
IT. ALL OF US WHO MAKE, MAKE IT
WORK. SO I APPRECIATE THE
AMAZING COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE STAFF THAT ALLOWS
US TO DO THIS YEAR. AND THE VICE
CHAIR, I SAID ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES, THE VICE CHAIR, WHY
DON'T YOU COME UP HERE AND SAY
THAT? THEN BUT BUT, OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP THE ROLL ONE
MORE TIME. SO FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO ADD ON BOARD, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CURRENT VOTE 16 ZERO.
EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN I GROVE 17
ZERO. ALL RIGHT. WE NOW STAND AT
17 ZERO. AND, I THINK OUR WORK
IS DONE HERE. COME ON. YEAH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. CARDI.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS. WE STAND
ADJOURNED.